I have to do one more follow-up about
the Jill Stein pseudoscience segment
because the emails have become totally
fallacious and that they are straw
Manning our commentary we did a
commentary two days ago ok about some
comments made by Green Party candidate
Jill Stein that referenced sort of
pseudo scientific ideas and they lack
depth
I'm not going to redo this segment today
because we just did it two days ago but
in the description to this video on
youtube we will link to the original
video um and we talked about Jill Stein
referencing debunked vaccine myths but I
made it clear Jill Stein has praised
vaccines and their positive role in
human history we didn't say she is an
anti-vaxxer at all Louis let's make that
clear yes that's true right yesterday I
received maybe 100 emails from people
pointing me to a recent interview that
the Young Turks did with Jill Stein
where they quote asked her about
vaccines and it quote proves I lied and
why won't I apologize so I checked out
the video and it refutes nothing that we
said it does talk about vaccines now for
those who don't know there's a logical
fallacy called the straw man and I'll
put that up for you on the screen the
straw man fallacy is misrepresenting
someone else's position in order to make
it easier to criticize so the formal
example would be person X takes position
a or makes argument a person Y attacks
position B which is a distorted version
of position a and then uses the fact
that they've rebut Edition B to suggest
that person X is wrong about the first
position they took it sounds crazy right
doesn't really make sense let me play
the video from TYT and then I'll explain
to you how it applies to the scenario
plain and simple yes or no do you think
vaccines cause autism no great cleared
up she and I say read my book okay I'm
on the record on this in the first
review of the literature that physicians
for Social Responsibility and I
co-authored a book on this
we were very clear when we reviewed the
science looking at what maybe some of
the public health drivers here
autism did that I'm sorry vaccines
didn't even make it into the list of
things that we considered reviewing
great so Jill Stein says very clearly
she doesn't think vaccines cause autism
case closed right well we never claimed
she thinks vaccine vaccines cause autism
what I did say is that Jill Stein's
references to debunked claims about
vaccines combined with her less than
articulate comments about both wireless
/ Wi-Fi and GMO taken together present a
pattern that lends itself to
pseudoscience again here is Jill Stein's
quote that I used on Monday where she
says as a medical doctor there was a
time when I looked closely as those
issues and not all those issues were
completely resolved there were concerns
among physicians about what the
vaccination schedule meant the toxic
substances like mercury which used to be
rampant in vaccines there were real
questions that needed to be addressed I
think some of them at least have been
addressed I don't know if all of them
have been addressed so super clearly she
is saying that she is a medical doctor
and that she doesn't know if some of
these concerns have been addressed these
concerns have been addressed the entire
thing around the dosing and scheduling
of vaccines has been addressed as not
being damaged damaging to the the health
of children the entire thing around
so-called mercury in vaccines has been
addressed so it's very frustrating Louis
and we'll put up now the actual version
of the straw man fallacy that was
applied by many in our audience here I
said Jill Stein's references to debunked
vaccine claims in the context of other
assertions are a pattern of
pseudoscience angry audience members
wrote to me saying David Jill Stein
doesn't think vaccines cause autism and
she's not anti vaccine and their
conclusion was that I lied about Jill
Stein
I really am disappointed Louis because
if we are going to have a real
discussion about these issues we can't
start by having me defend positions I
never took it sort of counters the
entire point of this program doesn't
it does I know that there are many
people out there as well that will will
either start watching part of a video or
even just look at a headline and yeah
and and think that they understand
everything that's happening right
vaccines was in the title so I must be
saying she thinks vaccines cause autism
without actually looking at the video
you can tell all the time looking at
YouTube comments that people did not
watch the whole video yeah I may have
just looked at the headline and this is
a huge problem and and if you are upset
at something we start saying during a
clip just watch the whole thing try and
stay calm yeah and and and analyze it in
detail based on what we actually said
rather than some position we never even
took hopefully this is the last
follow-up we have to do on this Gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly.com
slash TDP s